في طيران قال قائد القوات البريه في الحرس
الثوري الايراني ان ايران ستواصل استهداف
مقر ما وصفها بالجماعات الارهابيه المسلحه
في اقليم كردستان العراق الى حين نزع
سلاحها وزوال تهديدها وكانت مصادر امنيه
بمحافظه كركوك العراقيه قد افادت بتعرض
مواقع لاحزاب كرديه معارضه لايران للقذف
شمال المحافظه وقد اخلت السلطات المحليه
المدارس في المنطقه المستهدفه دون ان يعلن
عن خسائر بشريه من جهتها اكد خليل نادر
القيادي في حزب الحريه الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض سقوط ثلاث قذائف في
محيطي مقر الحزب في المنطقه دون ان تسفر
عن وقوع اضرار
في هذه الاثناء نفس سفير الايراني في
بغداد محمد كاظم ال صادق وجودنيات لدى
طهران للقيام بعمليه عسكريه بريه داخل
الحدود العراقيه ضد جماعه المسلحه كرديه
معارضه لايران وخلال مقابله تلفزيونيه قال
السفير الايراني في بغداد ان طهران تسعى
الى حل هذه المشكله
قبل عبر الحوار وتبادل وجوهات النظر وكشف
السفير الايراني ان طهران طلبت من الجانب
العراقي التدخل لحل هذه المشكله من خلال
نزع سلاح الجماعات الكرديه المسلحه
وابعادها عن الحدود المشتركه الى داخل
الاراضي العراقيه
ووضعه مقاتلها في مراكز للاجئين